Structs are a great way to
encapsulate values, but
we can take this one step further.
Let's modify the original syntax for
creating a struct.
Right now, we know that a struct
has the struct keyword and
then we give the name of the struct
followed by variables or
constants of any type, as many as we
want and these are known as properties.
So I'm going to go ahead and
make a quick change to this.
Here's the difference.
With this syntax, we can see that
a struct can not only contain variables
and constants, but
instances of any type.
That means you can have strucks that
contain strucks, that contain strucks.
Essentially, strucks
on strucks on strucks.
Let's say we have the struct
representing a Song and
inside the struct we have a property for
the song's title, its length.
And also properties for
the artist first and last name.
So as we define a struct like this,
maybe we decide that we want to include
some more information about the artist
like their age and their hometown.
We can go ahead and
add these properties like so.
But this is beginning to look exactly
like the problem we had before structs.
We just have a bunch of variables and
constants and they're starting
to get a little disorganized.
And all this related information
could continue to grow and
get more unmanageable.
The best way to handle this is by
pulling the artist data out of the song
struct and creating a separate
struct that represents an artist.
There we go now we have an artist
struct with first name,
last name, age and hometown.
And actually we could probably
get rid of this prefix
because that would be redundant.
Now here's the powerful part within
the song struct we can have our own
property which itself is a struct.
So let's do that now.
So now the song struct itself contains
an artist and this is really nice and
elegant and as we'll see later
expanding this to support
multiple artist is actually
quite intuitive process as well.
So how would we access the properties
of a struct within a struct?
Let's go ahead and
see a code example to explain.
First, we'll create an artist track.
How about country music
artist Garth Brooks.
We will use the syntax
we've seen before.
For the first name we've given Garth,
for the last name Brooks, age 53 and
home town is Tulsa, Oklahoma.
And this is according to Wikipedia when
I looked it up a couple minutes ago.
And now that we have our artist
struct creating a song struct
becomes pretty simple.
Let's create a struct for
his song Thunder Rolls.
So we'll use the song name Thunder Rolls
which has a length of 3:42.
And we could represent
this as a number but
we're choosing to do it as a string for
right now.
And the last property that this
initializer needs is an artist and
low and behold we have this artist
instance right here called Garth.
So we'll use Garth and there we go,
we have an instance of a song struct.
Now to access the information about
the artist contained within is
pretty straightforward and
uses the dot operator again.
So we'll start with Thunder Rolls
then .artist and if we go on we
look to see what it contains, we can see
all the properties of the artist within.
And if we want to take this one step
further we can use another dot operator
to access one of the properties with
an artist like last name in this case
which is Brooks.
So I'm sure you can start thinking
of some pretty complex and
cool relationships of
structs within structs.